chick-chick Willie Oh Kaitlyn my
disclaimer is that there is like a gene
in my family for being bad at languages
I went to Spain this summer I took only
French I'm hoping I don't embarrass
myself too much
Inari - I have absolutely no clue how to
pronounce this it's already like three
hats on top of these letters that I
don't know in our it - in our routine
you know yeah oh I didn't roll the arno
in Yahoo - is it America can't say
anything correctly you say it anyways
Ben yeah Nieto oh don't make me butcher
the president's name so like I should
probably know that it look like it's
penne penne Naoto and they they all
thought no I just said the same thing
Pina what again is it like an i or an a
or what is it are you two good eyes
there's so many letters there's way too
many G's an R oh my god this poor kid in
like elementary school names by
butchered all the time the first part it
looks like Aguilera
AG you Eric again you got an egg got it
I get it got it you again today I get it
you got it
I read guard right how do you say it
well that Rama I know this one that 70
show vulgar mama Valderrama fazool drama
around ma CH okay this look like a shoe
brand or something like that she's hot
you know this yacht you could search
ciacco quit yeah okay I just get images
so many choked
it's heavy yeah this is a sexier name
look this is a really expensive water
edia very echeverria hmm I never judge
people who have thick accent I'm always
like dude I get it I just want to say
that for the record
hopefully I wouldn't offend someone if I
said their name zuluaga
these are Spanish really zuluaga Oh Z
silent zuluaga I'm getting images of
Fabi over like Latin in prison a palace
way los Pollos palace swallows pot
laughs where loves everyone's so excited
because I prove that I'm not a complete
[ __ ] I felt like the substitute teacher
you know who can't pronounce anybody's
names with Massacre and there's like no
excuse all of them are various like sexy
Latin America I'm sorry it makes you
feel better I'm not much better with
English names
the audio department flappita me the
directors laughing at me
save your comment I already got all of
the change I'm actually happened